warum sollte man ein ziemlich dickes
Buch lesen was aus der Perspektive einer
Katze erzählt wird sie haben die
Antworten
[Musik]
philipp und ich sprechen über Machu von
Michael Köhlmeier und ich finde diese
Grundidee einfach genial die sieben
Leben einer Katze abbildet und zwar
jeweils in unterschiedlichen
historischen
Zeiträumen und damit uns die
Kulturgeschichte unserer Zeit näher
bringen wie ging's dir das
alles erzählt
ein Blick auf den Menschen geworfen wird
anhand ganz großer Konzepte auch Lüge
und Wahrheit Tod und Leben Charme und
Charisma was macht den Menschen aus und
es geht eigentlich darum dass der Mensch
sich durch deine seine Grausamkeit
auszeichnet und das ist aber
hauptsächlich
gelernt hat
Grausamkeit als alleinige Eigenschaft
des Menschen ich habe das nach ausgelegt
eigentlich dazu zu sagen der Mensch ist
ein Wesen was ich irgendwie seine
eigenen Wahrheiten zurecht legt aber es
ist eben doch gar nicht so leicht fand
ich jetzt wirklich zu sagen die Katze
zieht ein Fazit oder kommt irgendwie
darauf dass es jetzt das was den
Menschen ausmacht sondern ich glaube der
hauptvorgang da diese Betrachtung des
Menschen aus einer Perspektive die
erstmal nicht menschlich ist so viele
wie viele Sterne von fünf würdest du
Michael Köhlmeier erstmal zugeben vier
ich auch ausruht habe unterschiedlichen
Gründen natürlich
[Musik]